hi everyone I'd like to welcome you to
the talk titled growing the quantum open
source ecosystem
um so I'd like to introduce Nate steaman
who is a member of the technical staff
at the unitary fund
um so I will go ahead and turn the time
over to him
great thank you so much for the
introduction and thank you everyone for
being here and thank you to the
conference organizers for putting on
such a nice event so today yeah we'll be
talking about the the quantum open
source ecosystem and I'm going to tell
you quite a few different things today
but um just to give an outline so I'm
going to try to give a very brief and
non-technical introduction to Quantum
Computing we're just going to do a very
brief flyover this is not a technical
talk you will not walk away
understanding Quantum computation unless
you already do and more so just so we
can Orient ourselves we can understand
what Quantum computation is and why we
focus on growing in an open source
ecosystem surrounding it and then I'll
tell you a little bit about where I work
unitary fund and the ecosystem that we
are trying to develop or that we are
developing and um
yeah so let's jump straight into it
all right so so what is quantum
computation that's that's really the
question uh we need to start with and to
answer this question like I said it's
not going to be technical it's going to
be kind of a more historical and just
quick flyover about what what what
Quantum computation is
so one way to think about Quantum
computation is to think about how
science and history and uh particular
technological revolutions have kind of
interplayed and so when when
thermodynamics first kind of started
being studied in the in the 15 16 1700s
we
we started using that understanding of
how heat energy entropy how all of these
Concepts relate and we were able to use
those to build a new Machinery that took
advantage of those that Newfound
scientific understanding and there was a
lot of interplay we would build machines
and then we would then later
scientifically understand them and and
there's a huge interplay there
and this is playing pretty fast and
loose with some of the history but this
is you know this tracks with with other
things as well so for example
electrodynamics
um we were able to understand you know
how do electric Fields how do magnetic
fields how do they interact
um and we able we were able to use that
uh understanding of this field of
science and physics to then build
technologies that harnessed that
understanding and again there was a lot
of interplay and you can see here you
know we have some of the early computers
and and down here on the bottom right
um you know a computer that is requiring
multiple people to to kind of get it
running and and it requires like expert
operators and
um
yeah not not necessarily easy to use
technology and so you know those are
just two examples and so Quantum
computation can kind of be framed in
this light as well and so we've had an
understanding of the physics of quantum
mechanics for roughly 100 years now and
and just in case anyone is unfamiliar
quantum mechanics is the field of
physics where we study the very very
small things like atoms and molecules
and so we've understand how to model
these systems like I said for for 100
years and we have some Quantum
technologies that that uh have have
come of this for example lasers are a
fundamentally Quantum technology and and
we use those in our everyday life but
kind of the Pinnacle of
what we have dreamed of for for using
Quantum is is a quantum computer so
using these law these new laws of
physics that that we've discovered maybe
not so new anymore but using them to do
computation in some way like is there a
way that we can use quantum mechanics to
compute like we do on a classical
computer and so this is uh on the top
right here this is a picture of one of
the existing quantum computers that that
uh I think this is uh either
an IBM or Google machine as you can see
it's a very chandelier-like structure
and um
this is an example of a superconducting
quantum computer
and uh it they're very very complicated
machines here on the bottom right we
have an example of a quantum computer
that's using photons to to do the the
computation
and um
so that's that's kind of like what
Quantum a way to think about quantum
computers is this this historical back
and forth between science and technology
and and uh yeah we've had an
understanding of quantum mechanics now
we're trying to like really get it to to
do something for us and so Quantum
computation is is potentially the thing
that uh we can use our understanding of
quantum mechanics to do
and so the question is like where are we
now and so I showed the picture earlier
of uh of these two women working at at
this like very early humongous computer
and I I've put the picture of the of of
the Google Device on top of that because
that's kind of the point that we're at
we have we have
working devices but they're very very
limited in their capacity they're very
very uh difficult to operate this entire
thing that you see here is uh needs to
go into a refrigerator which is cooled
to almost zero Kelvin basically the
coldest things that we've created on
Earth and um
and uh they they're not very good is
basically the answer at the moment and
so there's two kinds of axes that we
need to look at is one how much uh what
what is the number of qubits that we can
do computation with and I'll introduce
uh briefly what a qubit is in in one of
the next slides
um but it's basically the thing that
we're doing computation on like the
information that we're Computing on so
how many qubits do we have and then also
when we try to tell a qubit to do
something how how frequently does it
actually do that thing and how
frequently does it do something else so
what is the error rate when we try to do
these computations and right now we
don't have a lot of qubits and we're not
good at controlling the qubits so we're
not able to do uh the computations that
we really would like these machines to
do so there's kind of two axes that we
need to push on one like scaling our
Hardware to to have more qubits and then
two pushing down the error rate and
having better control of these qubits
and that's kind of where we're going
because there are some potential
applications of quantum Computing that
require us to have kind of much better
control and much many more qubits than
we currently have
right so so what is uh Quantum expected
to do so there's this really nice quote
from Richard Feynman who was one of the
first people to uh dream up Quantum
computation as a concept and not
necessarily the first but but he said
nature isn't classical damn it and if
you want to make a simulation of nature
you better make it quantum mechanical
and by golly it's a wonderful problem
because it doesn't look so easy and
um in particular one of the things that
that Feynman uh was interested in was
using Quantum to simulate Quantum
because
the the laws of nature for quantum
mechanics are can be very complicated
partial differential equations that are
that are very complicated uh to solve
numerically or or they just scale very
poorly as as you increase your your
system size and so if you can use
quantum itself to simulate uh
for example chemistry problems we
potentially have much faster we can get
answers much faster and so that's one of
the first kind of
um
applications of quantum is to do
chemistry simulation so so there's two
kind of interesting things I think here
the first being
drug Discovery a lot of people want to
use quantum computers once once they are
kind of at scale
to simulate how a potential drug could
interact with the human body so it's a
lot of work that that has to undergo uh
between finding a chemical and then
doing human testing and part of that is
trying to understand like when when a
human ingests this chemical what what is
going to happen and there's just so many
possibilities and so using uh using a
quantum computer to simulate exactly how
molecules are going to interact with
with each individual part of whatever
part of the body you're interested in
could be potentially very useful
um
the other potential application is
forecasting
um I I can't say I know a whole lot
about this but I know that there's a lot
of banks that are interested in Quantum
computation for its potential to uh you
know be able to forecast whatever it is
they're trading in a more efficient uh
manner or or do better pricing and then
finally pretend potentially the thing
that people have heard most about is
quantum computers have the potential to
break uh things like RSA encryption
which is
um or or the the encryption that that we
use to secure internet communications
and this is true it does this is
actually what one of the first
algorithms that kind of put Quantum
Computing on the map in the 90s was by
by a man named Peter Shore and his
algorithm was basically a much more
efficient algorithm for factoring
integers and that's kind of one of the
problems that underlies uh our our
current Internet Security and um
so you know it's not something that we
really have to worry about now because
uh like I said our existing quantum
computers are very very small and
they're not even close to capable of
factoring the size of integers that
would be necessary to break or to spy on
someone's internet traffic and decrypt
what they're what they're seeing
um but you know
governments are are interested and um
this is kind of what put Quantum
Computing on the map for a lot of
governments and uh said oh okay maybe we
should be paying attention to this field
and and also don't worry because there's
lots of post-quantum cryptography that
is resilient to uh uh quantum computers
at least we think so so uh we we are
transitioning already in some areas
all right so so now the question is uh
okay great Nate like I see there's
potential usefulness of this in in our
society but uh
like why why here at Pi data like why is
this interesting to people that might be
here
and so first of all the the things that
you kind of need to know to do Quantum
Computing have quite a big overlap with
what people I think here might know at
least on the mathematical side so the
things you need to know some calculus
that's a kind of underlying a lot of
machine learning and data science you
know we know that kind of stuff a linear
algebra a lot of machine learning is
linear algebra we know that and then
Quantum is also a lot of more linear
algebra more there's a ton of linear
algebra and then there's some other
things that that go into the quantum but
there my point is that there's a there's
a lot of overlap in uh the mathematical
kind of ideas that uh
that that underlie these fields
and if you're interested this is kind of
like the Bible that people uh learn
basics of quantum computation by and
it's it's getting old but it still does
a great job so um that's just a resource
for you the second thing that I think uh
is potentially interesting about Quantum
to people here is um
when you do a computation that is uh
resource intensive you sometimes
Outsource part of that computation to a
particular part of your computer and so
this is a picture of a CPU and sometimes
you might want to Outsource part of your
computation to a GPU and there's also
other things for example this is a
picture of a tensor Processing Unit
which can can speed up parts of certain
uh
certain computations and this is a
picture of a qpu which is a Quantum
processing unit and so there is hope
that in the future
you may be able to take your complicated
uh maybe your training a machine
learning model and there's part of it
that you can send to a quantum computer
to to train more efficiently than
um
it would be to do on your on your laptop
or or whatever super computer you're
using
um
so yeah it's good good to have some
familiarity with some of the things that
uh you you might potentially be using in
the future if if maybe it's not a few
years away but still
and then yeah like I highlighted here
um the the programming aspect of things
is uh is quite similar so um
I think I do want to show you what a
Quantum program looks like but I need to
introduce some terminology first so like
I said before we have qubits that's the
fundamental piece of
uh
information I guess that we operate on
so instead of a classical bit that can
be a zero or one we have a qubit which
can kind of be any point on this fear so
maybe that gives you some intuition
about why quantum computers are
potentially more powerful or more
efficient at doing certain things is
because you have like a larger space to
do computation with
and then on the right here this is a
picture of what a Quantum program looks
like at least in the original kind of
formulations of uh dreamed up by
mathematicians and physicists and so uh
in the picture starting on the left you
have a three qubits that's that's what
we would have and then each one of these
boxes is kind of like an operation then
you don't need to know what what the
operations do but this is called a
circuit and this is how a lot of quantum
algorithms are specified and it's maybe
strange but um that that's how kind of
the physics happened and then it is
transitioning into a technology and so
it's uh you know the pictures are nice
though and they do a good job of
representing some of the things that we
want to do
so so those are the two terminology we
have qubits and we have circuits and you
can see how it might be similar to like
an electrical circuit diagram or
something like that and so now I want to
show you
[Music]
um
you know just so we can Orient ourselves
what is a Quantum program actually look
like
and uh so there's two kind of possible
not just two these are two of the most
popular uh front ends is what we would
call it to to write a Quantum program
the first one is called Circ
zoom out a little bit
and it's the the language that has been
developed or the it's really a domain
specific language is what is what uh I
think we should think about it as but
it's it's ultimately just a python
Library
and um
so this is what a Quantum program looks
like as you can see here we kind of
Define our qubit that we're going to
operate on WE Define a circuit and we
put some operations in the circuit and
so I've put one here which is we're
going to do a not gate but we're going
to take the square root of the not gate
and that's not something that you can do
on a classical computer because there's
no operation on the classical computer
that's a the square root of a knot and
so we're just going to print out the
circuit and then we're going to simulate
if if we actually had a real qubit and
we sent it through a square root of a
not gate and then we measured it what's
going to happen and so we can just run
this
and just just so we can see what it
looks like uh you know so here's our
square root of a knot and then
ultimately we ran with 20 repetitions so
we measured the zero State 11 times and
we measured the one state nine times and
uh so yeah there's some Randomness
involved so every time I do this uh
we're going to get slightly different
results but but that's the idea
and then I just want to show you what
what a relatively similar program but
with a different circuit might look like
in in kids kit as another popular front
end that people are using to write
Quantum programs and this is the the
package developed by IBM
so here we're going to instantiate our
Quantum circuit we're going to put some
operations on the quantum circuit and
we're going to measure and then again
we're going to simulate what happens so
can do that you can see we now have a
circuit with two qubits and when we when
we run this we only get the zero zero
State and the one one state so you could
imagine you know you could have a
circuit that that creates other
possibilities as well for example a zero
one state and a one zero something like
that so again there is some Randomness
so every time we run this we will get
different results but that's just the
general idea and I just wanted to show
this to so that we can Orient ourselves
a lot of people I think come to me and
say like all quantum mechanics is so
confusing you know like how could I ever
go about
you know learning anything about Quantum
programming or Quantum software and it's
really like it's just software we're not
doing anything different from uh from
you know machine learning it's just you
know a new language that you kind of
need to understand and yes there there's
some there's some complexity there but
it's uh it's not some alien thing that
uh is impossible to learn so I just want
to hopefully dispel that a little bit
okay so now let's talk about more about
the software ecosystem
and so the two the two examples that I I
just showed are both in python and a lot
of the ecosystem has been developed
around python there are
um
quite a few other options out there
um but a lot of a lot of the uh popular
languages and and things that people are
using are written in Python so
um
and as you can see from this uh very uh
quantitative graph
um
the uh there's there's a lot of options
today so for for whatever you want to do
um we we just showed the two two options
to write circuits but there's lots of
other things that you can do with these
Quantum programming languages or
packages and
um
yeah and so the thing that I guess I
want to highlight here is that
um
a lot of the quantum stuff started out
in research and so so there's some uh
there was some
had to say like
impetus to open source things because
you know when you're doing research uh
you're sometimes incentivized to do such
and and then really once
um
once Quantum computation kind of like
started becoming coming on the scene of
like becoming a real technology or
starting that transition kind of like in
this 2016-2017 I know things were
happening before that too but
um I think there was like an intentional
openness in the early industry to put
things out there and and uh I think you
know from the academic history and then
kind of like this intentional openness
and early industry we we have like a
pretty solid Bedrock of of things that
are available to us and that has allowed
us to
um
start building this ecosystem that uh we
hope to continue to build and and make
more robust
and um this is kind of the way that we
like to think about uh having an open
source Community is like
not not only do we want to have a lot of
trees but we also recognize there's a
lot of other components to having an
open source ecosystem that makes it
sustainable and that makes flourishing
possible
um so so a lot of people when they go
into a forest that you know they want to
go find the big Redwood and they want to
look at that and and that's very
beautiful but uh what what made that
Redwood possible is like the rich soil
underneath it and so there's a lot of
um
there's a lot of components that we need
to nurture to to grow a uh an effective
and diverse and flourishing ecosystem
and this is maybe why you see I had so
many animals in some of the previous
slides is uh you know just trying to to
stream this together in some way
um okay so so now we want to talk more
about the ecosystem I need to talk a
little bit about unitary fund and what
we do so a unitary fund is a non-profit
organization whose mission is to
grow the quantum open source ecosystem
and make it accessible to the most
people that we can and so there are kind
of two pillars to our work here
um
I guess before that we we can kind of
think of unitary fund as like a numb
Focus kind of uh organization but with a
particular focus on Quantum technology
and um
and so our two pillars are we run a
microgrant program and then we perform
our own in-house research and uh
software
uh writing programming really
uh so
the the micro grant program is kind of
like the big form of Outreach that we do
so I want to save that for for the
second part
um and I'll just talk briefly about the
research that we do
um so like I showed you there's there
there are big players in the industry
developing open source software which is
amazing
um
but that means that you know they're
maybe sprouting up these big trees but
there's lots of things that need to
happen between the trees to make the
ecosystem useful and
you know we need some of these smaller
shrubs down on the ground in order to to
to make uh them to make our jungle as
beautiful as really we like it and so we
recognize that there are products or or
packages that are not necessarily
incentivized by uh individual companies
or a for-profit organizations to make
and so that's kind of some of the things
that we are trying to build I won't go
too much into the the details but one
one project that we have is is Mythic if
if you ever come across a any Quantum
open source project there's a 99 chance
there there's a queue forced into the
name somewhere and uh so so we we are no
uh no stranger to that effect so Mythic
isn't is an open source error mitigating
compiler and that's mostly what I work
on
um and then we also have metric which is
a community
uh Quantum benchmarking platform so
we're in the very early stages of
quantum computers and we need to
understand you know uh how does IBM's
quantum computer compare to Googles and
how does that compare to Penny Lane uh
Xanadu and so
um
this is kind of becoming the go-to
platform to kind of compare and contrast
uh what what are the options out there
so that's one of the ways that we're
kind of trying to like fill in gaps in
the ecosystem is by spending our own
time and resources on building some of
those and then the the micro grant
program so the microgrant program is uh
a four thousand dollar micro Grant uh
and and no strings attached we're not
trying to gain ownership over anything
uh we're really here to create this
flourishing ecosystem that that we can
Envision and yeah we provide mentorship
um
most of our micro grants have been for
open source software but we have funded
other things for example uh online
events educational resources and
generally things that benefit uh many
many people
we're not interested in funding
necessarily like private events and
things were really dedicated to to
making sure that everything that we fund
can be accessible to anyone who's
interested and so thus far I think we've
uh we've given 72 micro grants I think
we've actually given a few more since
since this number was updated but they
haven't been announced so
um
a few more coming and uh yeah it's it's
really a global phenomenon we we've
given to 23 different countries and it's
led to quite a few different
Publications so people you know write
their software and then use it in their
research and um
make Publications about it and yeah
we've had over 30 different libraries uh
two startups have been spun out or have
been uh We've funded kind of uh helped
get start to startups and also a
non-profit and really the the microgrant
program is aimed at people who are
interested in exploring and so we
recognize four thousand dollars is not
you know enough to sustain an individual
for a long period of time but um
for people for for for you know students
who who maybe have a a grad student
stipend already this can really be a
nice benefit to them to kind of take the
code that they've written as part of
their research and maybe bundle it in a
way that is more digestible for for
other people and make it more useful to
um
uh the broader Community because a lot
of times research software as I'm sure
many are aware it gets used for research
and then it kind of gets thrown in the
trash and maybe maybe another grad
student picks it up some at some later
point in time but it's not usually
written in a form that is uh
accessible for anyone else to use and so
this is part of the idea with the
microgrant is just to to make
some of these really cool projects a
little bit more sustainable
and uh yeah again going back to this
this uh analogy with with the jungle
like
like cirque and kiss the two uh the two
plot packages that I've showed you know
they're they're creating these kind of
silos and and don't get me wrong like
they are amazing and we need them
um and we're just trying to help
encourage the growth kind of between
those silos and and like I said like the
the ground layer and the canopy layer
and these kind of uh these kind of
things so that's kind of
um
our mission with the microgram
another benefit to the micro grant
program is Workforce Development
and this is actually a pretty big
component to Quantum because
uh as Quantum has become more and more
hyped for For Better or For Worse a lot
of companies are trying to hire people
who are capable at doing Quantum related
things and uh right now it's not a lot
of people
um there it is there are far more jobs
in Quantum than there are people for who
are qualified to do those jobs
and um
and so so a lot of the grants that we've
given are people who are like just
breaking into the industry and it gives
them kind of their foot in the door and
they can they can say to a prospective
employer like hey you know unitary fund
gave gave me uh they thought my idea was
good and they've they've funded my
project and I you know I spent a few
months working on this uh on this
project and it was it didn't have to
just be a thing that I did on the side
um
and so yeah I think we've helped break
quite a few people into the industry
which is something that I think is uh
really important and
uh
yeah fulfilling as well I think I think
that's personally a really nice thing
that we've helped to do that
and then in addition
um the community building aspect so this
is kind of goes into a few of the next
things I'll talk about but um yeah we've
given 72 grants that's quite a large
community of people now because a lot of
the the grants are given to teams and um
so yeah it's kind of a network of people
who are are accessible to talk to and on
our Discord which I'll which I'll talk
about in just a minute
um so it's a group of people that you
know when other people come to us and
want to ask like you know how do I how
do I use this fermion simulator or
something I can say oh okay well uh we
funded that project or or we know
someone who who is working on that
project and and we can help kind of
people break into the field in that way
as well
and and these micro grants are going to
to building really like state-of-the-art
software as well it's not just hobby
projects that that uh are kind of fun
for a few people but but not many others
so just to highlight a few of them uh
crack
um is an open source uh Quantum
simulator and it's performing better
than a lot of the
the things that are being built by some
of the research teams at companies so
it's uh performing really really great
and that's by Dan Strano uh qnet Sim is
a we have protocols for for running
Quantum computation and so qnet Sim was
actually to do protocols for Quantum
networking
and um
that was for Stefan diadamo and then
Daniel Tan received a micro Grant to
build an a compiler and again it's
performing better than uh some of the
other uh projects that are that are out
there as well and so I just want to
highlight here that um yeah these are
serious projects and uh they're they're
really contributing to state-of-the-art
research and and state-of-the-art
software
one of the other things that we do at
unitary fund
um
is uh you know if we're trying to build
this ecosystem one thing we we want to
do is understand who the ecosystem is
and uh and how we can serve to benefit
it so last year we ran the open source
Quantum survey which you can think very
much like the stack stack Overflow
developer survey but again more specific
to kind of quantum
and so this is not nearly all of the
data we collected but it does just give
you a sense of kind of uh
you know who the people are so like 55
of the the respondents or researchers
which is
um relatively expected given that this
is
still very much a science and not
totally a technology yet but then a lot
of people who classify themselves as
software developers so it's it is a lot
of people who have just a relatively
typical run-of-the-mill software
development maybe a little bit of a
science
um
Bend who are really getting interested
in this stuff and there's a lot of help
that anyone who's interested can do
without Quantum knowledge there's a lot
of infrastructure that we're still
setting up and a lot of problems that
are amenable without
detailed knowledge of
Quantum computation and quantum
mechanics
on the bottom left we have uh kind of
the the software role breakdown and so
you know who what kind of role do you
play in your project so are you a user
you can see a lot of people are users
but there's also a lot of
you know project owner slash contributor
slash maintainer so like a lot of people
are owning and contributing to and
maintaining the software rather than you
know just having a majority of people
who are users and a few maintainers so I
think that's actually really good that
we we have a great mixture of that
and then uh here on the bottom right
uh yeah just just kind of where people
are getting their their information
about you know when they're when they're
working on some Quantum software where
do they go when they're we're stuck and
uh I think for me this is just a great
reminder that uh you know your
documentation is is so so important and
uh
I guess that's uh not something that's
too unexpected
um
but then also we have a Quantum
Computing stack exchange which is uh get
getting pretty popular so if you haven't
seen that I maybe maybe check it out
it's pretty interesting
um the other thing that that we do
um is we every year we have put on a
virtual hackathon called unitary hack
and this is a virtual hackathon aimed at
getting people new getting people
contributing to new projects and so how
we do this is um
we have open source Quantum projects
that uh that are participating and and
we give them uh usually it's around
three hundred dollars which again we
know that's not a whole lot
um and they're able to take that money
and distribute it across a set of
bounties that they can put up for uh for
the hackathon and then it's it's the one
coming up this year is three weeks and
people can
during those three weeks people can open
up uh pull requests and claim the Bounty
if if the issue is closed by by their
pull request and so last year we had 30
participating projects and we
distributed over 66 bounties for
amounting over three thousand dollars
and we had over 400 people participate
so I think uh it is a great way to get
people participating and get people
um
learning about new Quantum software and
and hopefully providing a little bit of
financial incentive to uh to get people
kind of uh doing that and and yeah maybe
it doesn't feel so bad doing it on your
weekend if you are able to get a little
bit paid for it
and then finally uh we run a a Discord
so we host our uh a lot a few Community
calls on it so like I said Mythic which
is the project I work on every Friday we
meet to discuss
to discuss our development there's a few
other projects on here as well which
Garner some interest and and people are
welcome to come and
just hang out at these listen uh
contribute in whatever ways they want
and then we have Quantum Wednesdays as
well which is kind of our weekly
weekly research meetings where we're
usually discussing a new research paper
or something Quantum computation related
and um yeah we use this Discord to to
kind of organize all of our projects
and sorry
and have Community Hangouts and
generally just uh
hang out with anyone who wants to come
come by
and uh so how does it all work we have a
a group of supporting members who who
donate money to us I think a lot of the
the key players in Quantum right now
recognize that they are seeing a benefit
from from the work that we do and so
they are interested in helping us grow
this micro grant program and and like I
said growing this this rich soil upon
which the entire uh industry can benefit
from
so we have these groups of people who
have donated to us and then in addition
to to these supporters
um
we we also do our own research and so we
apply for for government grants and um
yeah that that is a pretty big portion
of of where we get our get our money as
well
and in the in the last talk there is a
question about is is the government uh
funding some of this stuff and the
answer is yes we we do get government
grants for for some of our research and
then we also uh we recently uh were
awarded this grant uh for for this
program Pathways to enable open source
ecosystems and this is a National
Science Foundation Grant and it's kind
of just exactly what you what you'd
expect we're uh
um kind of using this uh this
opportunity to to grow a larger
ecosystem and the government is is fully
backing this so so the answer is yes the
government is is doing some work uh not
to say that they couldn't do more but it
is it is happening
and with that
um thank you everyone for coming and uh
thank you for the nice event
so we do have a couple minutes for maybe
one or two questions if anybody had a
question
okay
thanks
um
do you know anything about the sort of
quantum database thing uh as I want to
say is that like a polynomial speed up
is it that's a complete bust so it's
just completely pointless it's a nice
bit of math somebody did in the 90s but
there's absolutely no future you know
practical applications because it's just
never ever going to give you any
worthwhile speed up uh so I I think uh
we're talking about uh Grover's
algorithm which is which is a algorithm
to do uh unstructured search and it is
uh provably faster than than any of the
classical algorithms which is
interesting
um in terms of applicability I do think
that there are some some limitations but
I I still think um
I I think it is useful I don't think
it's just a piece of math I think uh it
will it will play into uh
the the quantum ecosystem eventually if
if we can build large enough quantum
computers and if we can get uh Quantum
memory to be to be a real thing
thank you
okay
um everyone you can start to transition
to your next talk if you would like to
and Nate I believe you are here for the
rest of the day yeah if anyone is any
any questions about Quantum or or about
the ecosystem that we're trying to grow
please uh don't be afraid to to talk to
me
thank you so much everyone
thank you